hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm about to do the ice bath photo
booth challenge I'm gonna get in this
ice bath and I'm gonna play with photo
book at the same time because I imagine
when I get cold it looks funny
literally
between my
bok-bok-bok
no that's dangerous
hurts yeah it hurts actually hurts dude
this hurts
and no one heard it feels like my feet
got one over by a train
oh thank you everybody so much for
watching this was the ice bath photo
booth challenge don't do this at home
it's stupid this is painful and dumb but
we're idiots so if you enjoyed this
video and you have laugh at it please
leave like for our own sake we're
miserable idiots oh this sucks so badly
but thank you everybody so much for
watching and please if you enjoyed this
share it around with your friends share
where you go show people how stupid we
are thank you again and as always I will
see you in the next video